House Speaker Paul Ryan will lead a
delegation to hurricane ravaged Puerto
Rico today the visit comes one day after
the House passed a thirty six and a half
billion dollar disaster aid package it
includes four point nine billion dollars
in community disaster loans to help
Porto Rico President Trump criticized
the territory's finances yesterday he
tweeted we cannot keep FEMA the military
and the first responders in Puerto Rico
forever David Agnew is in San Juan where
Ryan is expected to answer questions
about the relief effort David good
morning Charlie good morning Paul Ryan
said I'll take questions for 15 minutes
we're gonna be there and our question is
exactly how much money from that bill
the House of Representatives passed last
night is going to go to Puerto Rico the
president has said they can't stay here
forever but Paul Ryan has indicated the
island will get what it needs three
weeks after the storm made landfall
you've got 45 percent of people that
don't have water 83 percent don't have
electricity and the government says they
may not get it until March yesterday we
went to a Medical Center in Canova de
swert Oh Rico where a doctor seeing
patients took a break to go outside and
put diesel in a generator because it had
run out that's what it's like to be a
medical provider here in Puerto Rico
right now we also spoke with the retired
lieutenant general Russel Honore of the
US Army
he was the incident commander after
Hurricane Katrina he told us that he
believes Hurricane Maria was ten times
worse than Katrina in fact he called the
federal response here a crying damn
shame saying that they need more FEMA
personnel more military members and more
supplies to get the job done
more of everything that's right David
beg no in Puerto Rico thank you so much